j'accueille marley
[Musique]
m
ça
non
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver la
pulpeuse marlène mourreau à la celle
saint cloud en banlieue parisienne après
dix ans d'exil en espagne elle vit
désormais chez ses parents
son fils gabriel âgé de novembre est
venu passer ses vacances en france
auprès de sa maman ici c'est la maison
de l'enfance où j'ai étudié c'est
beaucoup de souvenirs c'est ma chambre
de jeune fille la hausse et j'ai
l'impression de retourner à l'enfant
leurs points retour au point de départ
alors que j'ai fait toute ma vie en
espagne je me suis marié je mange chez
mon fils et puis maintenant que je
divorce et que je fais plus de
télévision en espagne rodez par case
départ retour case est pas le père de
gabriel est un célèbre chorégraphe
espagnole marlène miss franche-comté
1985 a su rester dans le coup et garder
son énergie
[Musique]
guay c'est difficile d'être le fils ou
la soeur de quelqu'un comme arles est
très
exagéré genre lhenry
bêtises si j'étais madonna à voir
jaillir mais c'est pas moi je suis
plutôt pour sa famille pas toujours
facile d'assumer la sulfureuse carrière
de marlène comment ont-ils vécu ses
poses lascives et ses tenues si sexy moi
j'étais sûre d'elle c'était fier neige
et je vais m'asseoir la télé j'étais
fier qu'il serait pas fier de son frère
sa soeur de voir la télé quand je vois
ce qu'il y à la télévision française
actuellement ça me rappelle moi quand je
vais qu'elle en arrière quand j'avais 25
ans ils prennent toujours les blondes
pulpeuses pour faire légère valoir de
ces messieurs j'ai été la poupée
gonflante de l'eau du paf met dans la
boîte sénat mais résiste vous laisse je
m'en vais l'aéroport cabrié tu as bien à
un papy mamie séjour de départ pour
gabriel les vacances avec sa maman sont
terminés et l'on découvre une autre
marlène jeune mère moins exubérante
sensible et à fleur de peau venturer
jazz
[Musique]
oh
à
[Musique]
et maintenant direction l'appartement de
son associé et ami pour préparer son
come back une soirée à laquelle
l'ancienne animatrice se doit d'être vus
[Musique]
s'apprécie moins c'est que ma petite
soeur c'est ma petite soeur pour moi au
niveau professionnel
astral et elle est capable de tout
laisser tomber même son côté un objectif
parce que c'est nous vrai professionnel
en faveur d'auxerre et voilà c'est
pourquoi pas les seuls
j'ai pas de secret il est temps pour les
deux associés d'aller faire du shopping
pour préparer l'événement dont il espère
temps juste
l'heure tourne marlène et son ami
doivent maintenant se rendre à la soirée
n'est pas vraiment à l'heure mais bon
les stars sont toujours en retard c'est
très bien
[Musique]
le lancement d'une chaîne de télévision
sur les tares un événement
incontournable pour marlène qui espère y
décrocher le contrat qui fera redémarrer
sa carrière
mais après dix ans d'exil elle semble
pour le moins perdu au milieu de cette
foule
prenez moi
[Musique]
pour hamilton
trop malheureusement pour marlène le
temps a passé et la jeune génération
semble ne pas la reconnaître
je connais pas
les années 80
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
marlène
bonsoir world aux sentiers battus très
bien alors marlène vous êtes né le 19
avril
1969 mr dessinatrice publicitaires pour
des grandes marques de parfums alors
concernant votre père il ya plusieurs
versions il ya une version où il est
loueur de voiture avec chauffeur il ou
des limousines au roi fahd d'arabie à
elton john et une autre version où il
est le chauffeur de marennes dietrich ah
oui tout à fait il a été
longue carrière en tant que chauffeur de
grande remise donc il avait sa cécité de
limousines dans sa villa il a loué à ma
literie à elton john madden a un goût de
jean est et dans les années 69 70 il
était avec moi même des triches quand je
suis né alors enfance à perpignan chez
vos grands parents maternels c'est votre
grand mère qui vous avez jusqu'à ce que
je finisse mes études et ma mère et des
treize occupé avec ses ces études de
dessin et son travail dessinatrice
publicitaires et finalement c'est ma
grand mère s'occupait de moi alors
écoles de bonne soeur et oui entre
autres il toujours virer a toujours
virer tous les ans
tous les ans ma mère mes parents ont
cherché de nouvelles écoles pour la
rentrée de septembre c'était c'était
tout le temps comme ça alors ensuite je
vais à paris
pour passer un bac d'arts plastiques et
vous faites en même temps une école de
maquillage d'école chauveau je me suis
un peu mis sur le maquillage artistique
effectivement puisque j'étais déjà dans
le métier de la mode et du mannequinat
ça m'a permis de travailler sur les deux
facettes moi en tant que mannequin est
aussi en même temps en temps comme
maquilleuse à l'époque vous commencez
par des concours de miss beaucoup de
concours de miss oui j'en ai fait 30 de
nos 30 m à une trentaine vous avez été
dauphine de miss france matip voilà
alors vous n'avez pas été mise parce que
vous dites que valérie pascale elle elle
et elle est ce qu avec madame de
fontenay et finalement c'est même fonte
et a fait gagner ma dérive c'est vrai à
l'époque comme on y avait beaucoup
d'histoires
la fille du maire du 13e
l'élection était dans la mairie du 13e
l'avait le numéro 13 autres symptômes
bidart quoi j'étais un peu chelou à
l'époque il y avait pas la télévision
donc ce n'était pas contrôlée par parler
les votes bon alors moi je reste dans le
doute je voyais plus être france mais
non mais c'était pas ça c'était
méconnaître que ce n'est pas ma vocation
tout pas si tu ne peux pas gagner
j'avais les cheveux courts et jamais les
cheveux longs et madame de fontenay le
vocaux d'amy son cheveu long c'est vrai
c'est vrai alors question garçons vous
tombez en sept pour la première fois à
l'âge de 15 ans quand même hein ah oui
le premier amoureux s'étaient pas c'est
tomber c'est ton mais oui oui parce que
bon à l'école le premier truc qu'on se
dit tout le monde mais des préservatifs
forcément voilà du coup j'ai eu un petit
accident est bon mais ça arrive à tout
le monde de nos jours il y en a des qui
sont en simple plus jeune que moi non
seulement ça se sait pas parce que sont
pas médiatisés
ensuite 500 conquête quand même 500 oui
je sais pas je ne vais pas compter oui
qui vous a dit ça il paraît que vous ce
n'est que d'une centaine maintenant je
me souviens qu au moins d'une dizaine
vous dites je me souviens des hommes qui
savent faire l'amour je me souviens de
ce qu'ils m'ont donné de l'amour mais là
combien qui vous ont donné de l'amour
pour finir un ou deux maximum oui oui on
va dire le premier amour et puis après
le père de mon fils vous êtes fidèles
quand vous êtes avec un garçon vous êtes
assis voilà simplement que j'avais des
fidélités successives
c'est à dire que comme ça dure pas
longtemps général c'est vrai que le
temps que je suis à une personne je suis
fidèle à la personne comme moi elle est
tranquille mais sûre qu'elle a pas de
corps
mais en tous les cas je préfère quand
même vivre la passion et donc quand je
suis avec quelqu'un c'est parce que je
suis amoureuse ça me plaît la personne
âgée donne tout pour elle et c'est sûr
qu'elle cherche par ailleurs à ce moment
là et pourquoi ça s'arrête à chaque fois
ça s'arrête parce qu'ils deviennent trop
jaloux et possessif
et leur sympathie au moment où ça en
titre sur ma vie professionnelle et
chant même sur mon travail c'est là que
je suis obligé de faire des séparations
de l'été ça les voir privilégier votre
travail non je regrette pas parce que en
fin de compte j'ai toujours mon grand
rêve depuis tout petit c'était d'être
indépendante c'est pour ça que je
partage mes parents très tôt et d'être
indépendante pour tous donc j'ai jamais
voulu dépendre d'un homme et donc des
deux hommes il commence à vouloir des
pentes de toit ou qu'ils veulent te
faire dépendre d'eux c'est là que ça
être suffisant
alors à 18 ans vous commencer une
carrière de mannequin de charme se dire
quoi mannequin de chat même mannequin de
charme c'est à dire si les mannequins
qui qui sont les sujets et pas les
objets c'est à dire qu elle se dénude
parce qu'elles sont pas le portemanteau
elle mettra le vêtement
j'étais beaucoup d'années mannequin
devenue alors en 1990 donc 21 ans vous
fait vos débuts à la télévision sur m6
avec une émission qui s'appelle venus
oui vous êtes une speakerine topless
c'était la première émission érotique
est pareil j'avais déjà mon agence de
mannequins d'ailleurs mis toutes mes
filles étaient sur le sur le quartier et
puis moi je suis arrivé en tant que
directrice de mon agence de mannequins
pour contrôler le casting
et le directeur de casting mais mais
c'est vous qu'on veut voir à l'audition
alors du coup j'ai passé l'audition avec
mes filles et du coup c'est moi qu'ils
ont pris pour fermer la présentatrice a
duré trois ans votre agence de
mannequins s'appelait bodybuilding et
vous allez quand même des filles pas mal
ingrid chauvin oui avec sandra broker
tabatha cash et voulait recruter et
comment toutes ces filles sorties
d'école
sortie d'école je prenais des jeunes
filles qui étaient encore en plus ou
moins en cours et puis je les prenais
pour faire pour être mes modèles à mon
école de maquilleuses et donc je les
mariés et c'est la laiterie photogénique
c'est la très belle un visage
intéressant et c'est bon je leur faisais
un book et les faisait travailler à free
comme mannequin
la célébrité viendra avec patrick
sébastien vous l'avez connu e ou patrick
sébastien je suis content dans une
soirée où je faisais un spectacle de
d'une limitation justement et il m'a
vraiment faire garçons la suite c'est en
94 il m'a dit voilà moi je vais faire
louis de funès est en train de rêver
machin que je suis au lit avec madonna
et toi tu fais madonna suzuki dit bon
alors on est parti pour faire madonna
est là dessus ça fait une terrible aux
audiences et je commençais à travailler
avec lui à faire plein de numéro
d'imitation après c'était maemo non
après c'était d'autres personnes à
josette j'ai tout fait même les moches
donc s'il était finalement vous l'avait
acquis assez vite non mais je l'aï assez
vite sans le vouloir finalement puisque
moi elle en fait ce que je voulais
c'était de travailler et faire faire mon
buzz de l'argent et payer mon loyer à la
fin du mois comme tout le monde
cherchait pas être célèbre n'est rien et
puis on ne travaille avec patrick
sébastien j'ai rencontré aussi monsieur
pouvoir qui m'a fait travailler sur les
grosses têtes je faisais moitié radio
avait avec rtl et ben voilà quelles ont
été les réactions de votre entourage que
vous êtes devenu célèbre par exemple vos
parents vos grands parents ils ont réagi
comme ans mes parents mais je ne me
parlait plus depuis depuis 17 ans on
était il était fâché avec moi parce que
j'avais posé nue il trouvait que c'était
dans le mauvais chemin il croit que
j'avais j'ai commencé à faire des
bêtises et ses pairs alors qu'il
s'inquiétait un peu jusqu'au jour ils
ont vu que j'avais j'avais réussi à
sortir la télévision commence à faire
les couvertures de magazines et c'est
donc là vous pourrez consulter que vos
parents à ce moment là je me suis régalé
mais pas en ce moment là et puis et puis
ça a été ça a été un peu le le phénomène
de la famille dans tous les villages à
la grand-mère des grand père m'a chassé
la petite moureaux
avec les médias ça s'est passé comment
marmen avec émettait c était très dur
parce que j'étais quelqu'un d'abord
j'étais très jeune et j'avais pas ma
langue dans ma poche comme certains
savent et donc j'étais très naturelle et
très spontané g dit des choses peut-être
que j'aurais pas dû dire
j'étais trop direct bon alors ça
dérangeait beaucoup de personnes et puis
et puis avec le temps bon mais il avait
peur de moi je pense ils avaient peur d
un personnage trop explosive trop
incontrôlable si incontrôlable et
surtout j'avais pas de manager je me
suis faite toute seule vous regrettez de
ne pas avoir eu de manager avait pas oui
je regrette mais en même temps je savais
pas si une personne pouvait gérer tout
ce que je savais faire
parce que quand j'avais mon côté
spectacle j'avais mon côté théâtre
actrice j'avais mon côté meneuse de
revue et le côté présentatrice comme
j'avais plusieurs cordes à mon arc et il
n'y avait pas manager du nord mais tu
fais trop de choses en même temps il
faut concentrer sur énormément de
contenu est entré sur la même chose il
faut que je fasse différentes choses
pour jamais m'ennuyer dans la vie parce
que si tu fais toujours la même chose
finalement au bout d'un moment tu tu as
tu classe et quand je me lasse vite
comme avec les hommes d'ailleurs
je gagne de l'argent l'époque oui mais
bon par rapport à ce que j'ai gagné en
espagne c'était normal
nous en effet quoi de ce pognon
c'est comme tout le monde mais surtout à
l'étranger à l'étranger avec des gars
comme ils viennent bettencourt voilà
qu'est ce que ça a été le meilleur
moment de cette époque l'avant 95
c'était quoi le meilleur moment c'est
c'est le changement un peu brutale que
qui te retrouves à promener dans la rue
puis tout le monde sait comment tu
t'appelles tu te demandes des photos des
autographes tout le monde veut embrasser
une tout d'un coup tu te sens aimé par
tous
ses formes et d'aller faire les courses
au marché au supermarché c'est mieux que
le valiamin oui oui tout à fait bien sûr
et le pire moment de cette époque c
était quoi j'ai voulu essayer de faire
autre chose au niveau de la télévision
pour pas être sans arrêt le faire valoir
de ces messieurs et d'être arrêté les
trains de faire la potiche et j'ai vu
qu'en france finalement c'était blonde
avec des formes dangereux ex père a dit
pouvoir faire autre chose que la poutine
alors en 1995 vous présenter aux
élections présidentielles avec un parti
qui s'appelle le p le parti de la
liberté de l'amour ça encore les idées
de monsieur patrick un programme alors
c'était une journée de l'amour par les
préservatifs gratuits il colle et le
mariage homosexuel voilà c'était tout un
programme sur l'amour surtout l'amour et
que les gens apprennent à mieux s'aimer
à se réconcilier avant la saint-valentin
voulais qu'on soit férié des trucs comme
un pur c'est juste pour faire l'amour je
venais de lui c'était un mélange de nos
idées mais il était principal était de
lui voulait me mettre en tant que
ambassadrice de l'amour justement en
tant que le candidat et lui faisait pas
restée en arrière pour contrôler toute
la gestion
alors il a recommencé ya pas de temps
avec le tard non ça n'a pas eu plus de
succès d'ailleurs parce que le dard n'a
pas marché il a failli se faire virer de
la télévision et là il s'était fait
vraiment direct tf1 avec ça cette époque
en 95 on est parti de tf1 alors il est
parti de tf1 france 2 et moi je suis
partie en espagne et on était chacun un
chacun de son côté chercher son travail
comme il fallait et quand vous êtes
parti en espagne c'était un retour sur
terre un peu un peu brutale de vous
retrouver comme ça dans un pays
finalement ce personnage
m'a proposé de me présenter une émission
en prime time dans une langue que je
connaissais pas ce que fout
alors on m'expliquer l'émission en
anglais je le pensais en français je le
disais offrant en espagnol donc c'était
assez travail intellectuel alors pour
une blonde je m'étonne tout seul c'est
un super bien marché en plus et ça a
très bien marché puisque je suis resté
là bas 15 ans et mon émission a duré
trois ans et c'était sur la première
chaîne d'état et voguerez t2 d'avoir pu
faire cette émission en france j'ai
toujours regretté de ne pas avoir fait
toute ma carrière de 15 ans de
présentatrice et d'actrices de
personnages comiques en espagne ne pas
pouvoir l'avoir fait ici dans mon pays
normal
cette nostalgie de cette époque de tf1
nostalgique
non ce qui m'a fait me m'avait rendu
triste et à chaque fois que je revenais
à paris je voyais je voyais ce que
j'aurais pu faire que je n'ai pas pu
faire et j'aimais et ça des fois ça me
faisait pleurer j'étais j'avais ça va
monter là je dis oh la la il ya celle là
qui fait si c'est là qu'il fait ça au
lido j'aurais pu travailler au lido
moulin rouge alors que j'ai fait tous
mes spectacles en espagne dans des
casinos et est ici quand je me présente
c'est toujours à maintenant mais vous
n'êtes pas assez ou pas assez de la jet
set pour faire
c'est toujours quelque chose très
spécial les français avec l'image s'est
toujours voulue à quelqu'un de ce qui
s'est passé à l'époque
on peut en voir à personne parce que je
m'en vouloir qu'à moi même d'avoir été
d'avoir été tout feu tout flamme et pas
avoir pu contrôler c'est de ma faute de
ne pas avoir pris quelqu'un pour me
gérer c'est de ma faute de ne pas avoir
tout est ma faute donc marlène
sérieusement si c'était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas de la
même façon aux jo c'est ne pas avoir de
ne pas laisser quelqu'un me diriger il
faut toujours dirige moi que je commande
moi quand j'ai vu ce que quelqu'un peut
vous dirigez c'est ça le problème c'est
que quelqu'un soit pas quelqu'un que
c'est très difficile des policiers
personnellement tout de faire des gros
défauts de j'adore commandes et c'est
pour ça que mes hommes dans ma vie sont
partis en courant parce que même mon
mari mais j'en peux plus tu commandes
dans le travail tue commande à la maison
tu commandes pas
alors les jours vous serez mortes sous
les coups marquent sur votre tombe même
à
mais j'ai pas du tout pensé mourir mais
je ne veux pas mourir maintenant je me
vois pas du tout bord tout petit moi
j'ai une phrase c'est la blonde
explosive qui parlait trop mais oui mais
quelque part si on parle pas alors on
n'est qu'une potiche alain mais moi je
trouve que c'est bien de parler parce
que bon c'est vrai que des bêtises
missions sur l'ensemble des bêtises que
je dis est toujours quelque chose de
vrai
donc quelque part il faut que je parle
parce que si je parle pas je me dis bon
je vais rester encore dans le décor et
fameux pot de fleurs mais bon faut bien
ma rose est quoi
mais j'étais très heureux de rallumer la
lumière sur mon mari s'est jeté
plusieurs marchés rien bientôt j'espère
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il mettait
un peu de bleu